what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we can't down the top five
characters teams a concepts from across
the comic book industry and this week
we're counting down my picks for the top
5 moments from injustice year one number
five Superman kills the Joker as a comic
series it serves as a prelude to the
events of the video game and justice has
just as many awesome moments as it does
philosophical moments after being
tricked by the Joker into killing his
own wife Lois Lane along with her unborn
child and after blowing up metropolis
with a nuclear warhead
Superman travels back to earth and
punches a hole through the Joker no
questions asked there's no debate
there's no discussion no nothing he just
shows up in the middle of Batman's
interrogation and kills the Joker
what made this moment so cool is that
more often than not Superman leaves
Batman to deal with his own villains
even if they've done something in
Metropolis however for Superman this was
personal the Joker had waged a war
against him and his family costing the
Man of Steel the two things he valued
most
and so like Anakin Skywalker the death
of Lois Lane and their unborn child sent
the Man of Steel tumbling down the
rabbit hole resulting in a line being
crossed that he couldn't come back from
number four the Batman Superman debate
so following the death of the Joker at
the hands of Superman both he and the
Dark Knight get into one of the greatest
fights of all time except it's not a
physical battle it's more of a moral
battle regardless of the differences the
two have had over the years whether it
be their stance on society the function
of government or criminals the common
ground the Superman and Batman have
always shared was that they didn't kill
unless there was no other choice with
Superman having killed the Joker the
common ground was smashed to pieces and
the bridge between Batman and Superman
went with it and the eyes of Batman
Superman's incredible power coupled with
his steady increase in dictatorial
policies as he eliminates dictators and
imposes fear around the world is turning
society against the Man of Steel but
Superman doesn't care and his mind
society should be scared corrupt
politicians should be scared to take
bribe money rulers should be scared to
set off a nuke and criminals should be
scared to pull the trigger too Superman
Batman's willingness to allow the Joker
to live was the cause of all of this
and in truth The Joker should have died
a long time ago what this is is a
perfect example of utilitarianism one
man should die so that millions could
live for Batman however this is the
reason why he doesn't kill and his eyes
everyone potentially poses a threat to
everyone else if they is heroes with
their vast strength or incredible
resources began to use this as a
legitimate argument to kill in the end
the world would crumble and fall into a
perpetual war of all against all
furthermore the story establishes the
end of their friendship when a crisis
brews as a result of Aquaman's actions
when Batman admits as Superman is a
greater man than he is Clark extends a
metaphorical olive branch and asking
Batman to join him turning away from
this offer the end of their friendship
is solidified as the gap between the two
widens to an impossible distance number
three Superman versus Aquaman and one of
the most awesome moments from the year
one okhla man attacks a group of whalers
considering this to be an attack on his
kingdom Aquaman
sinks the ship and the fishermen along
with it and takes up arms against the
surface world with Superman Hal Jordan
Wonder Woman and Shazam responding to
the attack a showdown takes place
between the man of steel and the king of
Atlantis with Batman watching from the
cave and pleading that Aquaman doesn't
do anything rash
Batman's worst fears come true when
Aquaman issues an ultimatum as he states
the kingdom of Atlantis and the oceans
are his territory while he cares nothing
for what Superman does above land his
issues come when the actions of Superman
and his ilk involved the sea as he
explains the surface world borders all
oceans and if he wanted to he could
bring the world of Superman crumbling
down with an army the likes of which the
world has never seen while Superman
initially seems to give in to Aquaman's
statement his true intention is revealed
when he gathers Wonder Woman in Hal
Jordan by his side stating that if
Aquaman wants to demonstrate the power
of the oceans when Superman will
demonstrate the power of the surface
working together the three lift atlantis
out of the water and carry it to the
middle of the Sahara Desert
number two Barry Allen's crisis and one
of the most emotional and touching
moments from the series Barry Allen
watches on as an unnamed man leads a
protest against Superman Wonder Woman
and the rest of the Earth's heroes due
to their violent method
while the kid is told to stand down but
refuses to Barry Allen watches on as
this young boy is beaten within an inch
of his life and paralyzed in the process
as one of the wild cards in Superman's
regime this moment went towards Barry
Allen eventually switching sides against
the Man of Steel as he explains that
he's the fastest man alive and while he
could have stepped in and stopped
Superman and Wonder Woman he chose not
to this sentiment is further compounded
on when Barry Allen is led to the
advanced sciences and genetic testing
laboratory by Batman at an effort to
nudge the flash away from Superman's
side it's at this point that Barry Allen
learns this young man was named Mitchell
Davies and it met Barry Allen personally
and idolized the heroes of Earth when
Mitchell had risen up against Superman
and Wonder Woman in his mind he was
doing exactly what they would have done
if the roles were reversed and in the
process lost his ability to walk and
quite possibly his life number one
Alfred vs Superman as probably the
greatest moment in the history of
everything that's ever existed
Alfred single handedly takes down
Superman with year 1 seeing an influx of
multiple plot threads like Lex Luthor
developing super pills that give someone
the same powers of Superman the death of
Green Arrow and so on Batman had taken
one of the pills analyzed its
information and found a way to
synthesize it with Superman
interrogating Batman by way of torture
the Man of Steel is tapped on the
shoulder and turning around to find that
Alfred it consumed a super pill the
Butler of steel delivers a headbutt made
of nightmares
pummeling Superman into the ground and
stomping him to the point that his shoe
explodes from the sheer force
Alfred then turns around and picks up
Batman to take him away and stating that
there's nothing in the Batcave or saving
anymore with that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end and let me
know how you guys feel about injustice
do you love it do you hate it do you
wish it never existed let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace